We were having a
story when last seen.
I was back from the emergency
room the following day
and wondering, what
had happened to me?
And like all of you here,
hopefully all of you here,
I have the power of R and
RStudio, and I know
how to do an internet search.
So I found a blog
post that told me
how to export all the data
from the Apple Health Export.
And that's what I did.
And I also know ggplot and
I did this chart.
This is the very chart that
I took with me to my doctor
a couple of days later.
It's not a very fancy chart.
The vertical axis
shows my pulse.
The horizontal axis
is the time of day.
Zero is midnight.
And you can see about
there is the event that sent
me to the emergency room.
My perception of the event that
sent me to the emergency room.
In the middle of the
night, about 1:30 AM.
This is when I
was upset, got up,
took some bicarbonate of soda.
The whole thing did not last
very long, went back to bed,
went to sleep.
While I was asleep,
my pulse was going up gradually,
which is very unusual,
and then hit that
and off I went.
And that's the story of
my visit to the emergency
room, which was not a big deal.
It does provide an
example of how your health
tracker is basically making
a recording of your life
with data.
So in order to do this chart and
to look into this a little bit
more, I had to dig into
the Apple Health Export.
And the first thing that
sort of blew me away was just
the sheer volume of data.
Never in my
professional life have I
worked with a data set
nearly as large as me,
and I was kind of excited about
that and it was kind of fun.
So 3.9 million rose, 1.2 million
rows in the last year alone.
I mean, as we speak, I am
adding rows to the data.
And I also did some additional
stuff to try to say. was
this night unusual?
I went back and tried
to look for other examples
and didn't find anything,
which was a good thing.
So you have I have all this
incredible amount of data,
but if you think of it as
a recording of your life,
but if you had an audio
recording or a visual recording
of your life, most
of those moments
wouldn't be very interesting.
And the same is
true of the data.
There's a lot of
data, which is dull.
It's 70% of the data.
Is this sort of low level
stuff, your heart rate,
your active energy as
you're moving around.
And so on.
But there are a bunch
of summary measures
and other categories
of measures.
Basically, this is what
you see on the health app,
on the iPhone, or
you see these icons
with these categories of things
that it's keeping track of.
And underneath each of
those or with each of
those are sort of
individual measures.
And this is the
measure, the ones
that would fit on the screen.
There are quite a
few more than this.
And so you can get into
any one of these things.
Each of them has
a sort of a story
and maybe relevant
to different factors.
So you have heart
rate, of course,
but you but you have
your stuff about sleep,
which is not showing here
and step count and things
like that.
So lets
talk about, what is the
Apple Health Export?
So basically on
the iPhone, there
is a database of all
of this information.
And that's what's sitting
underneath the Health app.
And Apple, if you're app
developer on the iPhone,
the API to that database
is called the HealthKit.
And what's happening
is, is measurements
are being fed in
from the watch are
being fed in from the phone.
They're also coming
in from other apps.
For example, I have
Lose It on my phone,
which is a calorie counting app,
which I have occasionally used.
I have a blood pressure
cuff, which has a Bluetooth
connection to my phone.
I also have it set up
so it has a connection
to my electronic health records.
So it's all of the
records from my doctor.
All of that goes
into this database
and it becomes accessible
via the export.
And when you actually ask
for an export, in my case,
it takes it about 9 minutes
before it can assemble
this whole thing and then I
can export it to my laptop
and load it into R.
Now when I unzip this
export file on my laptop,
I think it's like 3 and
1/2 gigabytes, which
again is sort of crazy.
It's a very wordy format.
There's basically one
table that I care about
and that one is before I
process it in is like that one
is like 1 and 1/2 gigabytes.
So it is a tidy table,
this table. You don't
have to tidy it up.
It's already a tidy table.
It's got one row per measurement
for my 3.9 measurements
or whatever with 3.9
million, whatever it was.
And each row has a start,
time stamp, end time stamp,
the type of what
is being measured,
the value, and the source of
the measurement, the phone
or my blood pressure
cuff or whatever,
and the version of the software
that did that measurement.
So you'll focus on
type and value usually,
but you need to pay attention
to the source and the version
as well, the source.
So for example, your step count
is being produced by the watch,
but the phone is also
producing a step count.
They both get fed in.
If you don't pay
attention to the source,
you end up double counting.
And I've had that happen
with other measures as well.
So let's look at a measure.
This is resting heart rate.
I'm interested in, what's
the trend in resting heart
rate? We have on the
vertical axis, heart rate
on the horizontal axis.
We have more than four
years worth of data here,
one point per day.
And all of this feels
very personal to me.
So I look at a chart like this.
And I look at this thing and
I look at the smooth line
that I put through
this chart and I say,
whoa, what's going on here?
Why is this line doing this?
Is is there something about me?
Is, should I be
worried about this?
It's a trap you can fall
into by spending too much time
with your own data?
Should I worry about this?
Well, let's look at the version.
So the vertical green bars
show the major versions
of the watchOS
software, and you see
that basically
what's happening is
between version 6
and version seven,
they changed the measurement.
So what happened
with version seven?
They added sleep tracking.
So before version seven, when
they were saying resting heart
rate, what they were
usually ending up
with was my heart rate
at 3:00 in the morning
or when I was asleep near the
lowest heart rate of the day.
And they basically
redefined the measure,
let's say improve the
measure so that it
was only while you were awake.
You have to watch out for
this thing with any data set.
You definitely have
to watch out for it.
With the Apple Health
Expert, sometimes there
are clues to things like
this, but there are.
Sometimes there are not.
Sometimes it's a
Black box and you got
to figure this out on your own.
I'm going to show
one more example
because I like it a lot.
This is a measure I'm very
interested in VO2 max.
This is a measure of
your aerobic fitness.
When it's done directly,
you're in a lab
and they're measuring
your exhaled gases
and seeing how well you're
using oxygen. Obviously,
you don't do that
with an iPhone.
So they have an algorithm that
estimates your VO2 max based
on while you're walking
a certain distance,
you're looking at your
heart rate and the speed
that you're traveling
the distance.
I look at this
chart, I'm actually
pretty good at inventing
explanations for things
that don't have explanations.
But I look at this chart
and I can't see anything.
But if we add in
the version numbers,
we see that Apple is working
on improving their measures,
or I assume that's
what's going on.
And so you see that between
version four or version five,
Let's see, version
five, six, it goes up,
then it goes back down.
And then what's been
happening more recently
is less clear to me what's
going on with versions.
Maybe stuff is, maybe
it isn't, I don't know.
And you just have
to look at the data
and see. Now I would love
to know what my long-term
trend is for this, to
watch this over time.
But I look at this and certainly
for the earlier years now,
there's nothing I
could do with that.
And so for all of
these measures,
you can dive in and get
into stories like this.
So let's get into one
last measure, which
is different than
all the others, which
is the electrocardiogram, which
was added with the Apple Watch
four.
This is different
because it actually
has FDA approval as a
actual medical device doing
the electrocardiogram
and then also
the software that evaluates
whether it's showing
signs of atrial fibrillation.
Atrial fibrillation is a problem
with the electrical signal
in the upper chamber
of the heart.
I should emphasize
for this population
that it's generally a problem
among the elderly, not
a problem for the
age demographic
that is typical of
this conference.
You actually do the
electrocardiogram
by putting your finger
on the stem of the watch,
as is shown in the picture here.
And then to the right, we
have an actual little example
of the electrocardiogram
strip that it produces.
That strip is my strip,
indicates atrial fibrillation.
That was from October of 2020.
That's the second time I had an
episode of atrial fibrillation
in seven years.
I am I am elderly.
So it's not so far fetched.
Got into the news recently
because of John Fetterman,
the Senate candidate
in Pennsylvania,
was in atrial fibrillation and
it contributed to his stroke.
So what do I do in a
situation like this?
Well, I do a ggplot.
So again, I went to
when I had my episode
of atrial fibrillation, I
went to the emergency room.
My doctor is not
so surprised when
I walk in with a ggplot. I have
a beautiful blood pressure plot.
So this in the case of
atrial fibrillation,
I literally used
the same function
that I had written several
years before for the first plot.
In this case, I have
all the raw data
from the atrial
fibrillation episode, which
actually starts about 12:30.
What happened during the day
was I was having a normal day.
I went out for exercise
in the morning,
my heart rate slightly
elevated, all perfectly normal,
sit down for lunch.
Part way through lunch,
I felt funny, check and
realize something is going on.
So I have the raw
data for the electric,
for the atrial fibrillation,
but I don't have the expertise
to do anything with that.
That's just beyond me.
But what I was able to do was to
take the background heart rate
information and to put
the atrial fibrillation
episode in the context
of the rest of the day.
And there is some
slight relevance
to when I was discussing
this with the doctor,
because what I could show was
that within a minute or two
of after the episode started,
there's an indication there
that shows I was doing the
electrocardiogram. So I could
tell, this is evidence
that I knew when I
went into atrial fibrillation.
Sometimes people have don't know
they're in atrial fibrillation.
But I knew.
And you can also
see that I came out
of it before they hooked me
up to an electrocardiogram
in the emergency room.
It actually goes on and off,
like throwing a light switch.
So there was, none of
these things I'm showing
you have dramatic effects
on my medical treatment.
In this particular case, there
was some slight advantage
in having a discussion
about whether I needed to go
on blood thinners and whatever.
But the general point is,
is that this stuff shows
you a picture of your life.
There's a lot of data there.
If you have just looked
at Palmer penguins one too
many times and you want to try
something else with dplyr
you got.
You may have hundreds of
thousands and millions of rows
of data that you may
find more interesting
than Palmer penguins.
So I've done a series of
blog posts about this.
If you have more interest in
figuring out how to do this,
there's a lot more
information there.
And there's also a url, URL
with example, some other things
that people have
done with their data.
Thank you so much, John.